pourquoi était à l'hospitalisé votre
maman elle a fait une chute elle a fait
une chute chez elle et comme beaucoup de
personnes voilà
un peu agi elle a 78 ans elle est pas
elle est pas très âgée elle est pas très
agée mais
il y a
aussi un centre d'accueil de SDF dans
cet hôpital c'est ça le cache d'accord
pour autant donc ni vous ni votre maman
n'était inquiète de quoi que ce soit
bien sûr par rapport à cette
hospitalisation moi c'est normal faut on
laisse ça va mal à l'hôpital au
contraire entre les bonnes vacances
ce que fait le personnel soignant
généralement il est hospitalisé dans une
chambre double avec une autre patiente
et un homme qui n'est ni un patient ni
du personnel va alors rentrer dans sa
chambre
ça se passe quand ça en fait
ça se passe un matin
et là elle sent qu'il va se passer
quelque chose
et elle se met à dire elle voit qu'il
s'approche il apprend très brutalement
par les jambes il attire vers elle et
elle commence à dire vous n'allez pas me
faire ça vous n'allez pas me faire ça et
sa voisine comprend qu'il y a quelque
chose qui va pas elle commence à crier
toutes les deux elle commence à crier et
il agresse une première fois à ma mère
sexuellement
il faut savoir que ma mère ne pouvait
pas du tout marcher elle avait des
escarres sur une sur un pied donc elle
avait des bandages au pied les deux
pieds bandés et
et
donc il a viol une première fois
et ensuite elle
et surtout il fait quelque chose il
revient vers elle il essaie de la de la
violer une seconde fois et là elle prend
son membre et elle le tort
c'est la seule chose qu'elle a trouvé à
faire et c'est une bonne idée d'ailleurs
et à ce moment-là et non une infirmière
a entendu est entrée tout ça est passé
assez rapidement une infirmière est
entrée la vue de dos a vu la protection
de ma mère par terre et elle a sauté sur
le violeur et
le violeur a donné un grand coup de
coude dans le ventre de l'infirmière il
est parti en courant
donc
comme vous nous raconter ça on est
atterri et Adam à côté
elles hurlait souvent c'était le matin
les infirmières étaient un peu loin
parce qu'en fait il faut voir que il
faut savoir que la chambre dans laquelle
était ma mère était au bout du couloir
qui donnait sur une une porte de sortie
une porte de sortie de secours tout près
mais c'était la dernière chambre donc
c'était vraiment au bout par rapport à
la salle des infirmières qui étaient de
l'autre de l'autre côté c'est pas fini
parce que cette histoire est encore plus
folle parce que ce que vous allez
apprendre après est incroyable c'est que
l'agresseur donc a eu le temps de fuir
mais derrière il va récidiver
dans le même hôpital dans le même
hôpital une demi-heure après même pas
parce que l'hôpital dans l'hôpital il y
a
un EHPAD et il y a une dame
de 68 ans qui qui est rentré chez elle
et il lui a demandé une cigarette il l'a
croisé lui a demandé une cigarette c'est
bon elle lui a répondu qu'elle en avait
pas je sais pas ce qu'elle lui a répondu
et il a sauté sur elle il a frappé il a
alors là il a il s'est acharné sur elle
et la frappé et là et la violet voilà
donc votre maman elle se retrouve
ensuite dans la chambre avec
l'infirmière et sa
compagne de chambre qu'est-ce qu'elle
raconte tout à l'infirmière elle a alors
ça je ne sais pas trop je ne sais pas
trop ce qui se dit dans la matinée
je ne sais même pas à quelle heure la
police est venue sur les lieux ça je ne
le sais pas justement vous c'est ça
parce que ma question à quelle heure et
comment vous avez appris ce qui s'était
passé j'ai appris ça il était 14h à peu
près j'étais sur le chemin j'étais je me
souviens très bien j'étais dans le parc
que je traversais pour aller prendre mon
bus pour aller à l'hôpital et le et elle
la personne qui m'appelle me dit Madame
Mac madame enfin bref peu importe
vous avez vous venez à l'hôpital bientôt
je dis bah oui oui je suis sur le chemin
je viens oui parce qu'en fait on a eu un
enfin votre maman et un souci elle a eu
un petit souci bon elle nous a il
faudrait que vous veniez nous voir avant
d'aller la voir elle nous a autorisé à
venir vous à ce que vous on parle avec
vous avant
et je n'ai pas posé de questions j'ai eu
très peur je me suis dit elle a un
problème vous avez vous êtes dit
un problème de santé grave
donc je n'ai pas posé cette question
j'ai pas posé cette question
[Musique]
et donc là vous arrivez à l'hôpital oui
forcément vous étiez attendu là parce
qu'ils sont dit comment on va comment va
alors déjà ma sur ma première surprise
c'est quand je suis arrivée dans
l'entrée principale de l'hôpital il y
avait il y avait un
l'accueil l'accueil avait changé
c'est-à-dire qu'on m'a demandé ma carte
d'identité alors que j'étais pressée on
m'a demandé ma carte d'identité on m'a
demandé où j'allais dans quel service
qui j'allais voir etc et je pense
qu'avant ou pas
c'est-à-dire que ça avait été la il y
avait eu la levée du Pass sanitaire donc
on avait plus besoin de présenter ni pas
sanitaire et vérifier juste qu'on avait
un masque c'est tout mais sinon on
n'avait pas de on n'avait rien d'autre
et donc là alors que j'étais pressé
j'étais là en train de me battre à dire
ouais je suis pressé donc je suis
arrivée et les médecins étaient là tout
de suite
vous êtes allé dans une salle dès
l'entrée il y avait le bureau des
médecins donc j'ai toqué ah oui oui
venez venez avec nous on va on va vous
parler dans un autre bureau et là
j'avais
il me semble que c'était l'adjoint le
directeur adjoint de l'hôpital je ne
sais pas exactement qui c'était et puis
il y avait des médecins et qui m'ont dit
bon voilà
votre mère ce matin a
été violée
oui on vous dit ça c'est le premier
chose qu'on vous dit oui
ils ont essayé d'être le plus
délicat possible autant que faire ce peu
enfin vous dites
j'ai même pas dit par qui en fait moi
j'ai tout de suite eu peur de la
sécurité de tous je dis mais tout le
monde va bien parce que mon problème
c'est que je me suis dit mais ma mère a
été violée où est-ce qu'il est où est-ce
qu'il est ce violeur est-ce que tout le
monde va bien est-ce que les infirmières
vont bien est-ce qu'il y en a pas
d'autres qui ont été
du coup les médecins ont dit non non
mais c'est surtout votre mère c'est
c'est votre mère qu'on pense d'abord etc
bon oui d'accord mais
donc après
une petite discussion où ils ont dit que
il ne savait pas où il était etc je suis
allé voir ma mère
qui était tout petit que jamais dans son
lit
dévasté mais avec presque un sourire
parce qu'elle reste toujours digne elle
est costaud de ma mère
et
puis elle vous dit quoi
elle me dit elle me dit rien elle a
juste un petit sourire et elle est très
fatiguée
et elle sait que vous savez oui elle
sait parce que en fait j'ai rencontré
j'ai rencontré un brigadier qui était
très gentil elle était adorable donc
elle m'a expliqué un petit peu des
choses etc et ensuite je suis rentré
dans la chambre de ma mère et là il y a
pour votre mère à ce moment-là parce que
c'est
rien on s'est regardé en fait on s'est
juste regardé j'ai pris sa main c'est
regarder
vous avez des frères et soeurs
comme ça on se dit derrière voilà c'est
ce qu'on se dit à chaque fois c'est
qu'on devient fou tu peux tu peux faire
une connerie derrière quelqu'un qui fait
ça à ta mère tu
tiens voilà il en est où je m'adresse
aux avocats maître Bouchard et mettre
elle a mamouchi il a été appréhendé le
suspect absolument oui les placer il est
mis en examen et placé en détention
provisoire depuis le mois de septembre
[Musique]
en tout cas est-ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'effectivement des faits similaires ce
sont des rouler 30 minutes après dans un
EHPAD dans les lieux publics au vu et au
sud de chacun donc il y a tout lieu de
penser effectivement que potentiellement
un passif derrière ce jeune homme est-ce
que vous allez porter plainte contre
l'hôpital mettre à la mamouchi alors
effectivement alors une plainte a déjà
été déposée Cyril à l'encon de l'hôpital
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
une enquête est ouverte donc suite à
cette plante une enquête est ouverte et
cette enquête elle doit amener plusieurs
réponses alors effectivement notre
cliente se pose un certain nombre de
questions
le pourquoi et le commence là a-t-il pu
arriver quand je dis comment et comment
et pourquoi pourquoi elle
madame vient nous expliquer
qu'effectivement il était très facile
d'entrer qu'elle n'est pas manifestement
de filtrage lors des entrées on apprend
et c'est sorti dans des coupes
différentes coupures de presse que des
caméras de surveillance étaient
défectueuses est-ce qu'il y a des rondes
qui étaient effectuées est-ce qu'il y
avait suffisamment de personnel pour
pouvoir protéger cette cette dame
tout en ne pointant pas la
responsabilité sur entre guillemets les
soignants parce que ce que les soignants
ils peuvent pas soigner la sécurité
soigner contrôler l'entrée moi je le
vois dans les hôpital dans les hôpitaux
etc à l'hôpital moi je le vois on rentre
extrêmement facilement
et les soignants ils sont en train de
travailler ils sont dans une chambre
ils peuvent pas en plus faire la
sécurité
c'est vrai qu'à un moment c'est on en
revient toujours au même problème le
manque de moyens voilà faudrait par
service par étage par couloir une
personne de sécurité voilà mais ça coûte
de ça coûte de l'argent et aujourd'hui
c'est pas la première fois qu'il y a une
agression dans un hôpital et c'est vrai
que dans les hôpitaux quand vous y allez
le soir je vous dis vous dites on peut
rentrer dans n'importe quelle chambre
très facilement et les soignants les
pauvres déjà qui font leur boulot ils
font le tour des champs quand ils sont
dans une chambre en train de faire une
paire comme ça ils peuvent pas savoir ce
qui se passe et donc là c'est vrai que
c'est encore un manque de moyens et
aujourd'hui bien sûr
se retourner contre l'hôpital moi moi
j'ai de la peine pour les soigner parce
que même eux ils doivent se dire les
pauvres nous on fait ce qu'on peut on
peut et et ils sont au cœur d'un
problème enfin au milieu d'un problème
ils peuvent rien faire il faut qu'ils
aient il faudrait qu'ils aient plus de
moyens et aujourd'hui c'est vrai que moi
je le vois dans des hôpitaux
moi chaque fois je me dis voilà quand je
vais voir des proches je me dis c'est
vrai qu'on pourrait rentrer dans la
chambre mais n'importe comment vachement
bien c'est ça a toujours été comme ça on
se barricade partout maintenant
parce que la justice n'est pas là pour
répondre si on n'a pas le choix alors
regardez encore
à l'hôpital il faudra montrer la pièce
d'identité
simplement c'est absolument pas les
soignants qui sont dirigés par la plante
ça c'est important c'est l'établissement
hospitalier donc personne morale qui à
mon avis devra répondre effectivement en
tout cas il y a une responsabilité à
rechercher de ce côté là on sait que
effectivement le législateur avait en
fait avait mis à sa charge une
obligation de sécurité et de
surveillance donc c'est de cette
responsabilité qu'il va falloir étant
préciser que dans ce dossier on a une
porte qui est défectueuse une étude
secours qui peut s'ouvrir de l'extérieur
pour laquelle on avait déjà fait des
alertes en amont des faits et qui n'en
obstant on a reçu aucune intervention
d'un quelconque technicien
de ce que vient dire ma concert
d'ailleurs c'est une infirmière qui est
intervenue voilà pour faire l'agresseur
oui
les soignants aujourd'hui eux-mêmes
disent qu'ils ont peur de se balader
seul dans les hôpitaux donc encore une
fois la plainte elle est dirigée vous
l'avez compris à l'endroit de la
gouvernance la gouvernance des hôpitaux
vous connaissez tous la citation
gouverner c'est prévoir et je pense
qu'il était largement prévisible et qui
était et qui est l'incombé de la
responsabilité des dirigeants de prévoir
que un intrus que quelqu'un de mal
intentionné un agresseur un violeur
présumé était capable comme vous l'avez
dit Cyril de s'introduire dans un
hôpital et de procéder à des actes
criminels c'est de leur responsabilité
c'est ce qu'ils apprennent c'est leur
boulot c'est leur job et je veux dire et
ça aurait pu être encore plus grave pour
l'infirmière à la pauvre qui intervenu
et qui a pris un
couple
il aurait pu être armé et cetera ça
aurait pu encore plus grave et c'est
vrai que les pauvres les soignants ils
peuvent pas non plus soigner sécuriser
vers la porte d'entrée va tout faire
j'avais discuté avec un vigile j'avais
discuté avec un vigile après ça qui me
disait que des fois il avait des
médecins qui pourraient aller d'un
service à un autre service bien sûr
demander d'être et je trouvais pas ça du
tout normal mais après ça après le après
le viol c'est vrai qu'ils ont mis devant
notre service aussi invisible qui nous
demandait où est-ce qu'on va etc qui on
va voir mais après coup c'est toujours
après coup et la porte de la porte de
sécurité qui était la porte de secours
par où le violeur est passé elle était
défectueuse elle était défectueuse et
tout ce qu'ils ont trouvé à faire c'est
de mettre une une barre comme ça en bois
qui empêche aussi de sortir en cas de en
cas de dangereux aujourd'hui comment
elle va votre nom
elle est très très anxieuse alors
qu'elle était pas anxieuse elle est
encore à l'hôpital mais dans un autre
hôpital où ça se passe très bien et elle
va sortir lundi donc
on va rentrer chez elle enfin vous allez
rester beaucoup avec elle vous allez là
oui je vais je vais essayer de la
soutenir autant que je peux mais elle
est devenue très très anxieuse elle est
devenue inquiète pour tout tout le temps
alors qu'elle n'était pas comme ça et
c'était elle qui au contraire de temps
en temps me disait ne t'inquiète pas
donc
merci en tout cas merci d'être venu nous
voir merci merci à vous trois